foreign
Andy welcome back to the GSB thanks for
having me it is such an honor to be
sharing the stage with you your story of
founding bonobos from launching the
company here at the GSB in 2007 to
selling it 10 years later for 310
million dollars is truly inspiring I'm
so excited to dive into all of this
today but before we begin I wanted to
introduce bonobos to those of you who
may not be as familiar with the product
so in a view from the top first let the
fashion show begin
[Music]
on your left you have yes Jane an
Italian stretchinos on your right John
Henry Styles in original Stretch what
she knows
[Applause]
on your left we have Diego Ramirez an
original Stretch wachinos on your right
James Underwood in stretch watch Chino
2.0
oh my God
on your left we have ashawad Gupta in
yarn Dai stretchinos and Mike Pang in
slim straight Chinos
amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
on your left we have aramide olanian on
your right Jonathan Wilkins in original
Stretch what she knows
this is
[Music]
on your left Sonny Stevens in the
stretch weekday warrior dress pants and
Logan Randolph with the bonobos light
wall wash jeans
[Applause]
[Music]
last but not least on your left John
galhouli in stretch weekday Warriors and
Joel Bateman with the freshwater Chino
2.0
okay
please give a big hand for our models
[Music]
amazing I'm sure you've seen and been a
part of quite a few fashion shows not
like that not like that
me either
well Andy many people know you for the
pants that we just saw and if they
didn't before it they do now but not
many people know about what you refer to
as your ghost story
I'd like to read a powerful excerpt from
your book Burn rate if that's okay with
you
that sounds good okay
thank you
in 2016 on the precipice of selling
bonobos the startup I'd been building
for the previous nine years I flew into
a manic spiral and was hospitalized for
a week in the psych ward at Bellevue in
New York
when I was discharged I was met by NYPD
officers who took me to jail where I was
charged with felony and misdemeanor
assaults
oh good Cliffhanger yeah
thank you
um not many successful Business Leaders
talk about their struggle with mental
health so first of all thank you for
being so open and doing so
we'll spend a good portion of the
interview later discussing this but
every story has a beginning so let's
start with yours yeah yeah sounds good
you grew up in the midwest the son of a
U.S history teacher and an ultrasound
tech tell us a bit more about your
upbringing and how it influenced you
yeah
was funny because
the editor and my agent
basically said we we need a chapter at
the beginning of your book about your
upbringing and I my initial reaction was
there's nothing interesting about my
upbringing
I like I hadn't really thought of
anything
that unique about it and then as I got
to work on that I was like oh there's
some stuff here
my mom's a Indian immigrant
um born in a refugee town on the way
from raw Pindi Pakistan to New Delhi
India at the time of the partition
somewhere between one and two million
were killed at a time when 14 million
people were displaced
so her origin story is in the midst of
that Strife uh settled in New Delhi came
to the U.S when she was 20. her father
grew ill from emphysema he was the only
one who was of financial means so it was
financially extremely stressful
and her mother was a child bride so
promised me married at about 10 or 11.
married by 12 or 13 two miscarriages as
a teenager then two children who died in
infancy and then seven children
the middle of whom is my mom and my
mom's oldest sister my Mossy
delivered me she became an OB GYN and so
if you ever had this dynamic in your
family where you have an aunt who can
say to you I put you in this world I can
take you out of it you're being sassy so
that was a bit on my mom's family and my
dad's family were kind of classic
Scandinavian midwesterners
so you know
Danish Swedish Norwegian all of that
and so I grew up
um in a biracial household and I think
maybe the most interesting part of that
in retrospect for me is how different
the cultures were around communication
and so in my dad's family you don't talk
about small conflicts those Bubble Up
and become big conflicts and So
eventually you don't speak at all very
tragically he doesn't speak to either of
his living siblings
on my mom's side of the family you say
exactly what you think to everyone
except the person that you think it
about
[Laughter]
so it's a PR all the information gets
around but with no conflict my mom's a
little different with us and fast
forward to later now I'm married to a
Brazilian Jew who's descended of a
Brazilian in New York City Jews and you
say exactly what you think in real time
to everyone except the person to to the
person that you're thinking about such
that the first time I had dinner with my
now wife and mother-in-law either my
Scandinavian side or my Indian side was
in the bathroom dry heaving being like I
can't be a part of this family but in
truth was that might have been a family
you know coming together versus falling
apart so this is somewhat some of the
origin story for my family and I think
the other piece of it is my sister I
have an incredibly loving older sister
in Hindi we call it our Didi uh we have
a business together now which actually
is a really bad idea we'll talk about
friendship and business and family and
business in truth it's brought us much
closer together because we have more
time to spend uh but it also it's
challenging family and business is
challenging just as friendship and
business is challenging well Andy we
have something in common my mom also
tells me that she brought me into this
world and she can take me out so I've
heard that as well but you grew up in
the Midwest and you end up leaving and
coming to the GSB here in 2005 is where
the idea for bonobos was born yeah your
roommate and Schwab Brian spaley ended
up becoming your co-founder yeah take us
back to those early days of bonobos on
campus yeah and why men's pants yeah
so it was inverted actually
Brian was the founder of bonobos and I
became his co-founder and the way that
it went down is this Brian came in and
felt like there's this one problem that
he had which is his pants didn't fit
and so he did one of these projects I
can't remember what they're called uh
g300 it used to call the 300 project and
he went out and he got like the survey
with all of our classmates and the basic
insights were
guys wear jeans because
khaki pants and wool pants don't fit
that well so that was like Insight
number one and insight number two was
guys don't like shopping in stores and
then Insight number three was that J
crew and Banana Republic were like the
two main places
um so his view about men's pants was
very specific which is that if the pants
fit around your thighs and your butt
they were probably too tight in the
waist
so that when you sat down you were
really uncomfortable back in an era
where you had to where you had to wear
pants to work right and so then like as
soon as you got home you threw your
jeans on and like your weekend going out
was like denim
and the thing that happened in premium
denim in the 90s was there was stretch
that was added to the fabric which had
never happened before so step one was
Brian added stretch to khaki pants and
wool pants which was not a massive thing
at the time
the other Insight that Brian had was
that pants are kind of boring and so he
developed this contrast liner that would
peek through the back pockets they would
kind of create a conversation you know
they called a conversational prince in a
very specific place and he started just
selling pants to our classmates so he
found a factory in San Francisco
and he found a pattern maker in San
Francisco part of like the last dying
you know Vestige of the fashion industry
here and he brought pants that he had
worn where he would buy like a size 34
that fit his thighs and then tailor it
in to a 32 which is like a 80 alteration
probably that no one here has ever done
because you have bonobos right and
bonobos pants are made with that Contour
like curved waistband
so then he drove to La he bought a bunch
of fabric he picked a really cool like
pinwheel corduroy like really thin
really lightweight it had great stretch
which is kind of perfect for Northern
California because it's cool in the
morning and then it kind of heats up
during the day
and he just started selling them to our
classmates for a hundred dollars
and it was like well one person was
wearing them then five and then at some
point like half of our classmates were
buying pants we did a pants party at our
house I don't know if anyone has this
house on El Camino Real it used to be
called the White House
anyone live there all around today still
around yeah so
um Brian tried to Rebrand it Rebrand it
to pleasure town which didn't stick so
then it went back to the White House
Brian is an eccentric Accenture
character and hopefully many of you will
meet him in mge or have met him and we
had a pants party where people were
playing like whatever games and long
games and we sold 16 000 of pants that
day
and so if you ever have a product that
where you sell that much and it's a
legal product
[Laughter]
you might be onto something yeah
and you definitely were that is
incredible to sell sixteen thousand
dollars worth of pants in one day
after the GSB you decide to work on
bonobos full time while Brian decides to
take a job in PE and work on bonobos on
nights and weekends what gave you that
conviction I know so many of us
entrepreneurs and aspiring entrepreneurs
are wondering whether or not we should
take it that leap of faith
I went on a GSB service trip to East
Africa and it was like 12 or 13 you have
these Service Learning trips still
and
we did a Homestay for two nights and I
lived with a guy named Stanley
and his wife and two kids and it was a
clay brick house without running water
they
prepared a wonderful meal of course and
then there was like a big bucket where
you dump it over your head
um and generally it's cold water which
is like the Ice Bucket Challenge and of
course they like found a way to heat it
which was wonderful and it's also like
an outhouse where you shower or close by
and then I came back to the White House
um the one the one here in El Camino
Real and my um my bathroom you had to
walk outside to get to and it had two
shower heads
which is plush
and I turned them on and like the hot
water hit me and I had this moment where
I was like we do not actually take that
much risk
the way that we Define it in the U.S for
people in the cohort in this room it's
actually not risky to start a company
it's an insult to people whose lives are
actually risky to think of it as risk in
similar terms and and I don't mean that
in a judgmental way many of us have
reasons there are
medical cost reasons and children and
there are things to be thoughtful of but
in terms of having our futures our
future Net Present Value
is in pretty good shape
and so if you redefine the risk of not
doing something that you love
and that I think is a spiritual risk
rather than a Financial Risk and so that
trip really changed me and I felt like
okay even though I have three thousand
dollars in the bank and a hundred and
eighty two thousand of debt
maybe a third of which was elective just
having fun and traveling
um I'm probably not you know going to
starve one day
and with that perspective I was like
okay then what can we go do and I had no
good ideas of my own so I thought okay
I'll just steal Brian's idea
worked out well that is a helpful
reframe around risk and that reframe
allowed you to take the leap of faith to
move to New York and to work on bonobos
at the time you were truly a pioneer
building a direct consumer digitally
native brand just to take everyone back
to 2007
Amazon was a relevant in fashion people
thought e-commerce was going to be an
afterthought and if you were a fashion
brand not selling through the likes of
Burmese Barney's and Bloomingdale's you
were doomed to fail
so Andy how did you have this aha moment
to build a digitally native brand and
how did you convince others
well first what what is it a great
entrepreneurs are just thieves
and then second you know the future is
here it's just not evenly distributed
so if you want to build the future don't
look to the future look to something
that's in the corner in the present
and then kind of pass this prologue
which is that more or less we're the
same species you know last two hundred
thousand years so there's probably
something in history that that might
alert you to what was coming
for that third thing for me it was that
I'd worked at Land's End as a second
year Bane AC has anyone spent a couple
Winters in Dodgeville Wisconsin
um it's cold there's not a lot to do
other than just work and I got to see
this storied
um catalog retailer
that didn't have stores
and I remember one day touring the call
center
and seeing like all the notes from
customers that had been like mailed in
and there was a note from a woman that
said dear Elizabeth thank you so much
for calling me to wake me up the morning
of my wedding
my mom was a mess my bridesmaids wanted
to sleep in you're the best Carolyn
and I was like oh the Paradox of retail
is that by not having brick and mortar
stores and going direct and this was the
catalog Innovation you can actually
build a better customer service
relationship
and then in terms of what was happening
in the present that was in the corner
there was this company called Zappos
and an entrepreneur named Tony Shea and
backed by Sequoia and it was like you
know startups how there's like little
rumors you don't know exactly what's
going on you see that they exist and
they were selling shoes
and everyone at the time this was the
time where e-commerce people were
selling cars on eBay motors
but it was like well you're never going
to sell shoes because you got to try
them on or don't you have to drive the
car
um but Tony had free returns both ways
365-day return policy
and a really spirited service team who
were core to the company culture right
and that's obviously what delivering
happiness is about the book and the
irony of that title relative to Tony's
fate we'll guess we'll get to that type
of conversation later
so I was like well if you can sell an
existing soft goods product Footwear
then presumably you can sell in existing
soft goods product clothing
and
um
why can't you build your own brand
right and then I kind of looked at the
history of the gap which used to sell
Gap used to sell Levi's jeans and
records and then an entrepreneur named
Mickey Drexler came in and said well the
margins on Levi's jeans are here why
don't we make Gap genes we would get
another 20 margins well it's like well
you're a retailer with stores you're not
a brand
but he said no let's vertically
integrate that and now everything from
you pick it right from Ikea to Zara it's
all vertical now because of that margin
trade so I took those three ideas and
put them together and then I went out to
pitch people on the concept and everyone
said no
and that made me really feisty
and also as a part of you know a part of
innovation which is that it's got to be
contrarian at the time
well you were really on to something in
building this direct consumer brand
on the surface it seems like things are
going well this is 2007 2008 but
internally if you look under the hood of
bonobos you were dealing with quite a
bit of friction with your co-founder
Brian spaley as you've alluded to so can
you take us back to that time in the
life of bonobos and what happened there
well I blamed everything on him
right it's easy in life I think to see
someone else as the problem in your life
story and then if you get to my age or
Beyond you know 43 now at some point
hopefully you realize that you're the
problem in your life story
and it's a little bit debilitating to
take that on but it's also very freeing
because then you don't have to stand in
Judgment of others in the same way and
you also have agency to fix it if you
don't need someone else to change but in
2008 and 9 you know I was 28 29 years
old and I had these issues with conflict
that I described I wasn't able to
verbalize
conflict and have really difficult
conversations with Brian because he was
my friend
and now there's this whole school of
radical Candor that talks about if
you're high on caring but low on
conflict you're in a bucket that they
call ruinous empathy I was like that's
me I'm the ruinous empathy person and
the problem with ruinous empathy is in
theory you care about other people but
you care about them so much do you never
actually tell them the truth
right which is not that caring and so we
ended up in a place where
my anger was building and building
towards Brian for perceived slights
my stresses at the company as we hired
more people and raised more money we're
going up and I remember having a call
with one of the professors at the GSB
the only reason bonobos exists outside
of Brian's Innovation from a financial
standpoint is that two professors back
the company Joe Peterson and Andy
Ratcliffe and I called Andy one day and
I sent him our p l and I was like Brian
is got like we have a major inventory
problem we designed this swimsuits thing
it's not working and Andy literally on
the call was like you know the problem
on your PL is your Opex
it's your operating expenses which is
actually what Brian was I felt
criticizing me for but it wasn't
necessarily criticism it was challenge
because he's like we're hiring too many
people
and I was convinced that we had to bring
on a great VP of engineering from Zappos
and that we had to build this tech
company and Brian was like it's kind of
a pants company and I was like well it's
a tech company that sells pants
and so we had all these vectors of
conflict but we were unable to resolve
it
I think in retrospect due to my
limitations
and Brian's not perfect of course but in
our in our relationship the friendship
was ultimately sublimated to the
business discussion which is uh the
business conversations which is also
common so I I woke up at some point
dealing with a lot of depression I
really disliked Brian I wasn't so happy
with myself and that led to you know a
co-founder divorce that happened two
years after the the company's formation
yeah
given the conflict you described and
that leading to the co-founder split is
there any advice you would give to GSB
students in terms of thinking through
how not only to select a co-founder but
also safeguards to put in place in the
case of co-founder divorce
yeah so I think when it comes to
selecting GSB co-founders don't
[Laughter]
but if you insist
and I do think there's something to be
explored which is that the right
co-founder for your company might be at
Stanford but might not be a GSB student
someone from another school who brings
an entirely complimentary skill set
and very likely you're going to be the
CEO of that company which is cool
because CEO is a fun job
and you won't have the same kind of
complementary you know complementary
skill sets
if you if you do insist on founding a
company with a Stanford GSB classmate
and I wouldn't do it I wouldn't do life
any other way
there was no way for me to access what
became my life without partnering with
Brian because he was the product
innovator and the product genius
it's worth really thinking about what
you're going to do differently not at
Time Zero because that's pretty
straightforward but like four years
later
right so once the company has 40 people
how's it going to work because when
everyone's in a room it's kind of like
okay if you have two people running the
company
but once you have 40 people it's
extremely difficult the co-ceo thing I
love Ben horowitz's comment on co-ceos
when he meets them which is let me get
this straight it's more important to
optimize for your egos than it is for
having a clear decision maker at the
company
and it's a tough one to respond to some
people do pull it off uh friends of mine
Dave and Neil at Warby Parker have it's
remarkable but I I would hope that
someone at the GSB will write a case
about how they did it because it's so
rare and it's so much more often the
case that there is someone that leaves
before the other person
and that that leaving has acrimony
attached to it and I would love to teach
a case on a class on co-founder divorce
because there's a bunch from the GSB the
founders of StubHub didn't speak for a
decade they were Founders from my class
who had a venture together who were
married and literally got divorced so I
think it's important to if you're if
you're gonna do it recognize that you
are putting the Friendship to rest
the Friendship is the friendship ends
the day that you go into business
together because the partnership
eclipses it
those are good considerations and great
advice also I'm sure we would love to
have you can come back to the GSB and
teach that class
um Brian spaley does end up going on to
sell Trunk Club to Nordstrom so he does
have a successful exit of his own but
Andy now it's 2009 you're alone at the
helm of bonobos as the sole remaining
co-founder and CEO over the course of
the next eight or nine years you are
constantly innovating and trying to
figure out how to grow the brand whether
that's introducing new product
categories figuring out if you should
utilize e-commerce in different ways and
then continually innovating you end up
actually revolutionizing the brick and
mortar shopping experience with bonobos
guide shops so can you tell us a bit
about how you were able to innovate and
constantly see gaps that others couldn't
at the time yeah
um I love startups because they're a
collision of fantasy in reality
and there's many genres of
human work where you develop ideas and
you get to get really passionate about
those ideas there are a few where those
ideas are tested
and really have interrogated and
evaluated on a sub five-year time frame
and one of the most humbling things
about being an entrepreneur is that
you certainly have enough Vision at the
beginning to start something if it
exists you have done that
but the false conclusion that you might
reach is that you're going to be able to
do that again and again
and so you might convince yourself
that you're really good at vision
and the truth might be that you were
really good at the beginning
and so what I learned was the
innovations that were the most profound
were not ones that I envisioned but ones
that I noticed
and so we um just to talk about the
stores we had two fitting rooms that we
fabricated in New Jersey
that were ostensibly to take around to
do different pants parties and one night
we like rented out a bar and we invited
our best customers and it took 18 people
on our team to move
these fitting rooms and it was a massive
effort and we had a bar tab and everyone
drank a lot and we sold like eight pairs
of pants
so I was like well that wasn't great the
traveling fitting rooms concept is not
going to be our next thing and so they
sat in our lobby like collecting dust
and then when we were moving from
product one to product two from pants to
button-down shirts
thinking about how to like eliminate
some of the we called it like billowing
muffin top of like the shirt which you
saw in none of the gentlemen who walked
out it was a very tailored look
um we wanted customers to come in and
try it on and so we called it the dress
shirt Alpha we put it out on Twitter and
Facebook was a not reviled company at
the time and people came in and they
tried it on and they were like your
dress shirts suck
um but can we buy some pants and we're
like well we don't sell any pants here
and it turned into this thing of like
well can we just try on some pants
and so we had a fit run in Navy of every
like size
and then they would say like can we see
the other colors and they started
transacting and be like can we buy some
and it was like well we can just do an
e-commerce transaction in person and so
we at the time we were about a 10
million dollar business and we started
doing a million of sales out of our
lobby unintentionally
and I remember we had recruited a
merchant from J crew because after Brian
left I had to quickly fill the Brian
sized hole at the company which was like
merchandising design sourcing it in
production supply chain you know the
creative eye was hard that was the
hardest part about that year and our VP
of merchandising a guy named Brad
Andrews who's now up at Nike remarkable
person was like I kind of like what's
going on inside this little part of our
lobby
and so then we said well why don't we
try to experiment with putting that at
street level and the unit economics were
really interesting because we didn't
have to stock the store
and having uh sold watches at Marshall
Fields growing up and worked at
Abercrombie and Fitch on the night shift
this was 20 years before the documentary
so don't judge me but Abercrombie and
fit sweaters when I was at Northwestern
were the rage and they cost 72 dollars I
still remember this which I couldn't
afford so I was like I will go fold
sweaters at night so I can pretend I'm
rich like my classmates at Northwestern
very sad
and like folding sweaters on the night
shift kind of sucks right sweater after
sweater there's like the board you put
in and I remember thinking if we could
build a store where no one's doing that
what could we put in instead of the
inventory management we can put in
one-to-one service which we turned into
calling it The guides and we opened like
30 great stores and then we opened 30
stores where we spent too much money and
didn't need incremental doors in the
markets but that was I think the inner
that was the second innovation in the
history of the company after the selling
pants online Innovation well well these
Innovations helped you grow bonobos to a
company that was doing over 100 million
dollars in Revenue
it's 2016. yeah the world's largest
company comes knocking on your door yeah
and they end up acquiring bonobos for
310 million dollars
many people saw these headlines and were
wondering how this acquisition might
affect the bonobos brand so can you tell
us a bit about why an acquisition and an
acquisition by Walmart was the right
path for bonobos yeah
so we were right on the cusp
of doing a deal with a private Equity
Fund that's really good in consumer and
there's two of those globally
and that was a joke guys but it's hard
when you start a company it's hard to
identify private Equity investors who
you want to work for it's a big change
and so we figured out a way to barely
work for them which is they were going
to buy like a 40 stake in the company
we were going to maintain the majority
as existing investors
and they made a really good offer
and I went out to dinner at a restaurant
called Auto with my CFO and our general
counsel the founder of the firm and the
partner that had worked on it and they
gave me the term sheet at dinner
and I walked home which was a few blocks
to where Manuel and I shared an
apartment on 9th Street they'd give me a
bottle of wine as a gift and I was like
fumbling with the keys because I was
about to show my wife a 300 million
dollar offer
and as I was fumbling I dropped the the
offer and the bottle of wine at the same
time
and there was this guy named Newton
who said the two things will drop at the
same right regardless of size and so the
bottle of wine exploded on the offer and
so I walked in with an offer that was
like dripping red and I was like Manuela
I've got the blood Money
no
we're selling out
um and
during that process and in truth I
really did like these people and I felt
like they got it they had this thing
they needed to do which is they needed
to put their Capital ahead of everyone
else's in the in the stack in the
preference stack
and I was like you guys just got to the
party why are you the first in line and
so we were messing around for weeks and
weeks and then I heard from someone hey
you should talk to Mark Laurie Mark had
found diapers.com and sold it to Amazon
then he founded something called Jet and
it was wild he was like came out of
Amazon and was like we're going to beat
Amazon and the Rumor was that he was uh
burning 20 million a month in cash
and then he sold the company to Walmart
for three billion which was the only
buyer on planet Earth
so who does that
um and I walked into meet Mark in
Hoboken and he was wearing a Vineyard
Vine shirt and I was like I didn't walk
in here in an effing Amazon t-shirt
um he he didn't care that much about the
meeting but then we sat down and we mind
melded on this concept that the future
of Commerce might look a little bit like
the history of video which is that
initially the big platforms were
streaming other people's movies and
shows and eventually that was a race to
the bottom on price and so they would
need to develop their own content to win
and when Netflix launched House of Cards
and Orange is the New Black if you go
back and look at it their share price
took a hit because Wall Street was like
what are you trying to do become HBO
and in fact that turned out to be an
astute move so Mark and I mind melded
that I would come in and run this new
digital private brand group at Walmart
and he said you got to meet Doug and I
went
um down to Soho one night and met this
Doug McMillan unassuming guy for dinner
with Mark
um and he how do I put it I came out of
the dinner being like it would be a
privilege to work for this individual I
I fell in professional love and I'm
still in professional love with Doug
McMillan he's the best leader I've ever
seen in action and we should get him up
in this chair at some point
and I was like whoa it would be really
cool to see this Walmart Amazon battle
play out with a not a front row seat but
a second or a third row seat
well it's CR it's quite impressive that
you became a part of the digital
transformation of the fortune one
company and this obviously was such a
big milestone in the life of bonobos and
all throughout you growing and scaling
the company you internally are dealing
with so much so I'm going to Pivot now
and talk a bit about your bipolar
disorder diagnosis
tell us more about not only the
diagnosis in college but also your
initial reaction
yeah so I was diagnosed when I was a
senior in college I had
few weeks where I kind of took my
partying to the next level I was already
drinking a lot smoking a little bit pot
but I moved into a bit of ecstasy and I
had my first experience with psilocybin
mushrooms which for me luckily was the
last a few weeks later it was the turn
of the Millennium so it was 1999 to 2000
and it was a very exciting time because
you know there was this Y2K narrative
about how the digital world was going to
melt down and then there was this like
what does the New Millennium mean
and so as I was using substances and had
really fallen in love in a really
meaningful way for the first time in my
life I was watching one night a special
on people who thought that this was
going to be the end of the world
or that the Messiah was going to arrive
and as my mood escalated at some point I
realized
I was arriving
I thought that I was the second coming
and part of what is so humiliating about
Mania is that we have these mess ionic
grandiose delusions
um and when you come out of it you're
like oh everyone now knows that I have
this underlying God complex and so it
took multiple years later of therapy for
my my um my psychiatrist who I
affectionately refer to in the book as
Dr Z to make me aware that everyone
actually has a God complex
and the God complex begins in infancy
because when you scream you get milk
and when you cry you get comforted this
is for the vast majority of infants not
everyone sadly and so we begin Our Lives
as our all-powerful beings
and then we slowly part with that
reality year by year
at the same time as Disney and Harry
Potter incept us with the possibility
that we may be orphans who turn out to
have superpowers which is to say that
our popular culture is built around the
like struggling childhood to superpower
thing and so we
um most of us discard the idea that we
have superpowers should they ever come
up when you're psychotic and one of the
things that might help you understand a
person in psychosis is that you don't
have the ability to disregard that
thought
the irrational thoughts that you might
have at any point in the day the plane
hit some turbulence we're all going to
die right or
um
that deer maybe that's my daughter who
passed on like the the movie with
Francis McDormand those kinds of
thoughts are Fantastical and they're not
discarded by a psychotic person and so I
spent a week as Jesus 2.0 and it was
amazing
it's amazing
being the Messiah when manic is so fun
like if you actually believe that's true
and then it turns out that you're
actually the biggest liability on the
planet for everyone around you so you
know I stopped
um eating I stopped drinking anything
including water
uh I stayed up for we think four nights
in a row
and uh somehow through my friends
figuring it out calling my parents my
parents bring me home
me lecturing my dad on all kinds of
stuff my whole theory was that I was the
Messiah and my message and some of you
may like this message is that God is
actually a woman
it's like why did men get all this like
credit throughout history when women
like make life
um and so I was like yelling at my dad
about this and I was like all your
heroes are white guys and uh my dad was
like a master he just went full Socrates
on me and was like
and then they called over my aunt the
one who made me who delivered me and
they called and my uncle who are both
Physicians and they sat on either side
of me in the back of a car and took me
to the hospital and that happened to be
a hospital where I worked growing up in
the hospital where my mom worked which
just like compounded the humiliation
afterwards and so when the diagnosing
physician said you have bipolar disorder
type 1 I remember thinking
on no no I don't like that's what is
that I was two weeks ago I was having
fun with my friends I don't even know
what that means and then I went home and
I did some learning and found out that
the suicide rate for the suicide attempt
rate is 60 and the suicide rate is 20
percent
so when you're 20 and you're like well
there's statistically a one in five
chance I'm going to end my own life
and by the way this whole Mania thing
can come back at any point could be two
weeks or ten years and you might do
anything in that state like cut off your
ear
um
it's very hard to take that diagnosis on
as a 20 year old in its most frequently
diagnosed between 18 and 25. and so back
to the family Norms of communication
very different families but one thing
the cultures did have in common was an
abject desire to not speak about Mental
Health
and so my diagnosis became a little bit
like Fight Club which is we don't talk
about Fight Club right we just buried it
and my friends buried it too and so I
internalized that as an unspeakable
shame right because what is shame but
what is unspeakable and the amazing
thing about the human mind is you can
actually bury this trauma yourself
so I became unaware that these events
had transpired and then occasion would
like remember
this thing that happened to me in
college like I wouldn't even I wasn't
even aware and then I would remember and
I have this Rising panic and fear wait
what does that mean is that true and
then push it back down and I lived that
way for you know 16 years and I lived
asymptomatic for the first eight which
lulled US collectively as as a family
into
um
feeling that perhaps it had been an
inaccurate diagnosis and then you know
bonobos years depression kicked in and
ultimately it came raging back
Yeah you mentioned it came raging back
can you tell us a bit about that episode
that I described at the beginning of the
interview where you found yourself in
Bellevue for a week yeah so one of the
most pernicious things about Mania is
that it can be triggered by positive
life events having a child getting
married let's say selling a company in
my case it was falling in love with
Manuela and
coming to the decision that I was going
to ask her to marry me and I did it in a
very romantic way when while manik I
showed her a picture of the Ring which
is a great reveal right I I was
um
so excited during that time in my life
that I kind of replicated the going off
the rails of going out a lot drinking a
lot not sleeping Munch you know Sleep
Quality is poor if you're drinking a lot
she left she was working and spending
time in Beijing at that moment and While
She Was Out I was just like going off
the rails like burning the candle at
both ends which wasn't like terribly
uncommon for me but it was more acute
and when she came back I was I was off
but she wasn't quite sure how to process
it because while I had told her that I'd
had this incident in college I told her
what also was true
which was that
bipolar disorder is a differential
diagnosis and
people aren't always like definitely
sure that that's what it is it's both
over diagnosed and under-diagnosed and I
had gone to a few mental health
professionals in New York
um
when when I was dealing with acute
depression
and most people were like the company
that you're running that's a really
stressful thing and you don't strike me
as having this illness and so I had a
few people who kind of like dismissed it
so she wasn't really prepared uh and it
got bad that night I was lying in bed I
was howling at the moon I was playing
Tupac really loud and like music sounded
so good and she didn't know what to do
so she called her mom her mom came over
her mom you know lived in New York and
they were trying to kind of comfort me
and manage the situation and I got up
with a start to go to the bathroom and
we we lived in like a little garden
apartment where there was kind of like a
low ceiling and I hit my head in the
ceiling and cracked open and was
bleeding
um and it hurt really bad plus with the
Mania you feel more acutely
and we'd like had this like fight with
our landlord and there was uh there was
like a heating grate that had rats that
could come out of it and I like hated
our landlord and so I did something I
had wanted to do for a long time which
is I ripped the grade off and like threw
it
and then I punched a large like glass
window pane and opened up
um both of my Knuckles here and I can
still see the scars as kind of a
I take it as a healthy reminder of
what's possible
and then Manuela came to like help me
and I remember seeing like the fear in
her eyes
and my immediate thought was like and
this is sort of weird but I thought she
was the alien from ex machina
because she kind of is like stunningly
beautiful and smart and a little bit
robotic sometimes with her intelligence
and logic
and so I struck her and then her mom
came out and the felony charge was that
I pushed her mom to the ground and I
kicked her
and they were extremely Brave
her mom Manuela got her mom to the
bathroom her mom called 9-1-1
eight New York police officers showed up
within about two minutes
they pinned me to the ground
cuffed me and took me to the psychiatric
emergency room at Bellevue where I spent
a week unaware of what had happened
and as I came down from it Manuela came
to visit every day which was incredible
I noticed that she had a black eye
um
and it was about day five or six and I
just said did I hit you
and she said
you're kind of a wuss and it didn't hurt
and then it was like a noose to the sky
of shame to know that that had happened
wow
so how did you think about your bipolar
disorder diagnosis and what do you do
today to help to keep it under control a
bit
yeah
um so coming out of the hospital walking
into handcuffs the next six months were
were like a a hellscape
and it was was Manuela going to leave me
was I gonna have to step down for my job
was there going to be PR about it
um I remember being in the precinct the
fourth precinct in New York a place I
never thought I'd be it was like across
the street from my favorite restaurant
this Italian restaurant called lartuzzi
I never even noticed that they're this
is going to sound funny but like a cute
Police Department across the street and
now I'm in the South they're the
arresting officer is the one booking me
he's took my mug shots and I said
um officer are these mugshots going to
be online and he was like yeah but dude
you're not the founder of Google
you sell pants
and that was true that was true right
like if I had if I had had a higher
public profile there probably would have
been pressed because of the mug shots it
was under my legal name Andrew Dunn
which is not a thing and I was in and
out of court and there are court
reporters but like it wasn't it never
happened on the pr front
I was supported by the board
Manuela stayed with me but with
condition which is that I took my
medication and saw a doctor
and I became religious about staying
healthy I started seeing a psychiatrist
in lower Manhattan twice a week for 45
minutes
I did whatever he said medication wise
and that included six months of
experimentation where I felt suicidal
every day
and I also knew because after the big
high is usually a long low the big high
is fast it's like a week
the low that follows it
can be a half a year or years depending
on the kind of treatment that you
available and I had great Treatment
available which is a fundamental
Injustice that we have in our society
which is that mental health is
reimbursed at a very low rate and it's
hard to find the right provider
but I got through that and so now I have
a pretty robust system of
medication I still see that doctor twice
a week
and sleep is so critical sleep is
foundational so I have a sleep report
that I send screenshot uh of a Fitbit
report a WhatsApp group and it goes
every morning and so everyone knew
yesterday which is a little bit annoying
because I know my mom worries about it
still the night before last I slept four
hours and 33 minutes
and everyone knew I was coming to get
this talk which I was excited about and
so like last night was like a high
pressure sleep night
so I was getting dinner it was fancy I
treated myself to dinner no boo last
night
and I was at the bar and I looked down
at the menu and I saw like
cocktails that look good and then I saw
you know the non-alcoholic Yuzu thing
it's like 15
and I had three uh
and then I had a friend text he's like
you're in town do you want to meet up
and I was like oh I so badly want to
meet up and I was like I can't slept
four hours big day tomorrow and I went
home and I took the right medication my
doctor and I had a plan and I had an
eight-hour night and I sent it to my
family and like my mom was like good you
know so it's it's humbling to be in this
kind of a dynamic but I know I know that
transparency with my loved ones is a
critical part of my health and therefore
theirs
so it's a pretty uh it's a pretty
Olympic regimen at this point yeah yeah
well it's great to hear that you have a
process that helps you today and whether
you have bipolar disorder or not mental
hygiene is so important and I know
mental health is the focus of your
newest Venture pumpkin pie so tell us a
little bit more about that yeah so
pumpkin pie started as an idea to find a
husband from my mother-in-law
um who's amazing she's amazing and she's
how do I put this
um she's very talkative
and boundaries are not her strong suit
so um she's got a lot to offer and you
know she's lonely I think she'd be okay
with me saying that so we started the
company as an idea of like how do we
build a dating app for senior citizens I
had been a founding investor and board
member at hinge so I got to see like the
Social Mobile like dating Wars play out
and I remember thinking uh as I spent
time entertaining the idea of of helping
my grandmother I should just go with her
on the dating apps
so I like took over her match account
have you ever dated as a 75 year old
woman
um the guys aren't the best at writing
the profiles
um and yet there's so much knowable at
that stage about someone's life right
when you're 25 so much of your life
stories in front of you when you're 75
there's so many choices and experiences
you've made how you spent your
professional time whether you got
married or not did you have kids it's
this amazing amount of knowable
information and it's not really there
other than the profile so we developed
this
um it's kind of a game where you reveal
your personality by opining unpolarizing
things and then we hired a computer
scientist from this school and I
recruited a GSB friend to be my
co-founder
some learning some lessons Die Hard
um he's the founder and CEO of chess.com
as his day job so he's at an
entertaining last couple of months
and we built the algorithm in the app
and it had zero predictive ability
around romantic relationships
um but the sample group we send it out
to included people who were platonic
friends with each other and it was
highly predictive of platonic friendship
and so that's when we kind of said maybe
we could build Tinder but for platonic
friends and the problem we've discovered
with that and the reason it hasn't been
built is that the two ingredients in a
platonic friendship are mutual
vulnerability and continuous ongoing
unplanned interactions
and so how do you plan off of an app an
unplanned interaction and that's the
conundrum that we're trying to
um transcend we will stay tuned
Andy I have one final question for you
before we have a quick lightning round
this is a question that we're asking all
of you from the top speakers this year
yeah principled leadership is Paramount
at the GSB what do you view as your role
in leading with responsibility to not
just your organization but also Society
at large yeah
so I Love Ken Chanel who ran American
Express one of the uh the great black
CEOs and Pioneers and he ran MX through
many things he was a phenomenal CEO and
also through 911 and coming out of 9 11
where some 50 American Express employees
perished he came out of that at some
point and said that the job of a leader
is just twofold it's two bullets two
words each create hope Define reality
and I love that and I think creating
hope and defining reality are almost
impossible to do at the same time
because reality is scary
and bleak
um and then hope
is something that we need to magnetize
people to follow us
and we need to lead them somewhere win
some and so I look at where we are
societally and hope is hard at the
moment
hope is hard from a climate standpoint
hope is hard from a
a Justice standpoint whether racial
gender
sexuality otherwise hope is hard from a
political divisiveness standpoint
there's a lot to not be hopeful about
and yet your job
is to be hopeful
and to convince other people to be
hopeful to the people who will be
following you in whatever you do next
and then your job is also to not let
those people down by not being realistic
about what you're trying to do and doing
those things together it takes a rare
human that can do both of those things
and many of those rare humans are right
here
well thank you that's a great note to
end on we'll do a quick lightning round
now just in the interest of time this is
a view from the top tradition so Andy
I'll ask you four questions and please
say whatever comes to mind first okay
I'm ready I'm being at the doctor's
office yeah
so the first one is best piece of advice
ever received you catch more flies with
honey nice
and the Cubs will win the World Series
20 34. oh wow okay
most memorable GSP class
um interpersonal Dynamics yep fan
favorite favorite bonobos pants print
um the Pink Panthers before the
trademark shut us down
I wish we had a model wearing that today
Andy you didn't give your talk here on
campus when you're a GSB student but
thank you so much for coming back and
sharing your story today yeah thank you
yeah
thank you
[Music]